Star Trek beyond is a fun fast-paced
space romp
but just like any great action movie
these days it still includes more than a
few head scratchers here's a look at
some dumb things in Star Trek beyond
everyone just ignored random chance
creepy bad guy crawl is looking for an
alien artifact that was chucked into
space hundreds of years ago so how
convenient is it that Kurt happens to
randomly end up with it after a totally
unrelated diplomatic mission it's also
handy for 'crawl the Kirk kept it on
board his ship instead of sending it
somewhere safe log that the bolts lock
thank you
oh and the fact that he brings it to the
closest possible outpost to crawl space
is a pretty lucky break as well you know
considering the endless vastness of
space and all dangling plot thread when
everyone takes the escape pods and heads
for crawls planet Scottie drops out late
navigates his pod down to the surface
when he gets there he realizes he's
landed it on the edge of a very big
cliff and finds himself at a classic
fast and furious style action scene
where he has to run up the falling pod
and grab hold of a tiny ledge hanging
off the cliff then we cut away and the
next time we see Scotty he's safely
wandering around the planet at the
bottom of the cliff so how did he get
off the cliff Scottie is known for his
big brain but not for his epic mountain
climbing skills unless he jury-rigged
the jetpack we'd expect the scene to end
with him just falling to his death
those darn drones so Kraus whole thing
to get this artifact is to create a
deadly bioweapon but since crawl already
has a seemingly unstoppable drone army
capable of taking out Starfleet's most
advanced ships why not just attack with
that style points plus we find out those
drones are based on some ancient mining
tech left on the planet so how to crawl
turn a bunch of mining robots in the
universe's most dangerous fleet does
that mean some jerky supervillain will
just be able to weaponize all the drones
we have flying around here on earth this
amazing innovation then lowers it so
slowly to the ground drops off the
package and flies straight back up to
altitude do we just figure out the real
reason that Amazon's Jeff Bezos made a
cameo in the
movie Cheers total recrawl Jayla has
conveniently been living in the USS
Franklin for years and has used a fancy
bit of cloaking tech to keep the ship
hidden from crawling his minions but one
scroll is revealed to be the long-lost
captain of the Franklin it begs the
question how did he not already know
where his ship landed space amnesia a
long night of drinking space beers yeah
it's probably the space beers that's
usually it beastie bikes let's make some
noise okay so no one's gonna dispute
that this was probably one of the most
fun scenes in the movie and yes we loved
the Beastie Boys too but even though
it's been a running gag since 2009 Star
Trek reboot the fact that The Beastie
Boys are still supposedly relevant three
centuries from now is actually pretty
silly don't agree here's a quick quiz
named a pop star from the 1760s while
you're googling that we also have to ask
about the motorcycle that plays a
pivotal role in the finale why is there
an ancient motorcycle on the USS
Franklin and how is it still working
after all this time between the bike and
the Beastie Boys it seems like director
Justin Lin really just wanted to make a
cool 80s biker flick instead who does
spidey-sense we get a peek of the USS
Franklin's old crew footage midway
through the film though Kirk and
everyone else turns away before a dress
elbow appears in the frame but a hula
circles back to the footage late in the
film gets a look at the long-lost
captain and immediately deduces that the
captain is actually crawl
[Music]
it's him but how he doesn't look
anything like that anymore
does she have facial recognition
software along with a GPS tracker in
that necklace Spock gave ur lieutenant
Uhura wears of a kaya amulet which I
presented to her as a token of my
affection and respect you gave your
girlfriend radioactive jewelry the
omission is harmless doctor but it's
unique signature makes it very easy to
identify you get your girlfriend a
tracking device that was not my
intention or maybe all that Vulcan
radiation gave her superpowers that let
her see through Hollywood prosthetics
terrible security when crawl makes his
move and attacks Yorktown pretty much
the only people around to help stop the
body from unleashing his virus are Kirk
and the members of his team along with
of course Greg Grunberg but this is
supposed to be a fully man
top-of-the-line space station so why are
there no actual security measures the
only time we see anyone at all is when
the Yorktown mall cops run right past
the bad guy like a bunch of well mall
cops good job the big questions a big
chunk of Carl's plan is built on the
fact that he's able to hack into
Starfleet and figure out where the
artifact is to stage his attack on the
enterprise so if he can contact
Starfleet why didn't he ever just like
call them for help isn't he like a few
hundred years old how does he even know
how to pull any of this off
how is crawl able to hack into Starfleet
at all is he a member of anonymous
Scotty wrote the script now it's
important when considering some of the
goofy or aspects of Star Trek beyond to
remember that Simon Pegg co-wrote the
script
that's probably why Scotty can suddenly
scale sheer cliffs finds a hot space elf
girlfriend right out of a hobbit and
then somehow manages to get the USS
Franklin running again in a matter of
hours more than a century after a
crashed face-first into a planet knowing
that Scotty is basically a walking deus
ex machina also explains how he was able
to teleport 20 people at a time during
the film's epic escape sequence just a
few minutes earlier he didn't trust it
to beam out two people at a time which
is why bones nearly got nabbed by crawls
thugs at least I won't die alone that's
just cold but when the plot needs it
suddenly he's totally cool with just
transporting entire football teams with
no problems sure how many people can
Franklin transport at a time with a wee
bit of modification 20 max bomb not sure
how long it would hold out oh and then
there's the part where they jumpstart
the Franklin just by flinging it off a
mountain despite the fact that we're
told the Franklin wasn't designed to
even function in the planet's atmosphere
of course it's no surprise that he
struggled riding the 13th Star Trek film
to science shows dipole is not sure as
eggs as extras every odd-numbered Star
Trek movie hmm thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]